[Music]
great so thanks a lot for the the
invitation to come speak and it's been a
real pleasure to to see all the talks so
far and interact with everyone here so
my talk I think is gonna be a different
flavor of sorts than you've seen so far
today it'll be perhaps less algorithmic
analysis and more kind of discussions of
some of the challenges that we have in
devices today for going towards
applications of interest perhaps not an
approvable regime but perhaps in a more
heuristic one so hopefully there's still
something for everyone and I'm happy to
take questions if something isn't clear
but with that let's move onward so this
is a slide that I like to show and say
different things about depending on the
audience and it's kind of a fun graphic
he's not meant to be super accurate by
any means but it talks about the
excitement about quantum computing as a
function of time and you might say that
say it had some peaks and bumps along
the way say around the time that Shor's
factoring algorithm came out and a lot
of three-letter agencies got scared and
people got very very excited about these
things and you start to try to build
these devices and your excitement wanes
a little bit because it turns out to be
incredibly difficult in the more recent
past devices have been getting better
and better and our knowledge of say
error correction and algorithms has also
gotten better and better and somewhere
in the middle I would say a confluence
of things happened but ultimately we had
a few qubits that were good enough and a
few ideas of how to use them that it
seemed like it was no longer an
impossible physics problem and more like
an incredibly challenging engineering
problem and so at this point excitement
started to build and build and devices
have gotten better a lot of industrial
players have entered the government's
now put a lot of funding behind these
types of projects and we're building up
and up and up and this year the we're I
guess it was last year our team
announced this quantum supremacy
experiment which as many of you know was
a big technical achievement but really
was aimed at designing a task that a
quantum computer would be especially
good at so in a kind of hand-wavy sense
it was trying to find some task
for which I could race a quantum
computer against a classical one and
show that it came out ahead in some
serious way in terms of compute time and
so this was kind of the the tenor of
this and along the way it's basically a
great integration test for a device that
hopefully you get into this error
corrected regime and so a lot of the
algorithms that we've heard about so far
and a lot of the ones that we dream out
like Shores do live in this error
corrected regime which assumes that we
view through redundancy made essentially
perfect qubits and that we can do almost
anything we want but there's a question
of whether we can start to do practical
applications before we have these
perfect error corrected qubits and this
is sort of what I mean by using a post
supremacy device for practical
applications it's a device capable of
running this race against a quantum or
classical computer doing some tasks but
now I'd like to ask can it do more tasks
that I'm interested in and I think if we
can really find even a few great
examples here it helps bolster our
mission to get to error corrected
quantum computation in the sense that it
excites people and finds a new things so
this is kind of the area that I'm going
to talk about primarily so for us I'll
just put one slide up about the quantum
supremacy result to show kind of the
what we're proud of in terms of our
device error rates there's I guess an
entire week devoted to something like
quantum supremacy later in this Simon's
foundation so I won't get too much into
detail but essentially for us in
addition to this nice race against
classical computers you can sit down and
look at what are your one and two qubit
error rates not only for the isolated
qubits on this 54 qubit device but while
running them all in parallel which
presumably if you believe in things like
cross talk and engineering complications
is a harder task and what you find so
since it might be hard for you to read
is simultaneous parallel operation
single into qubit gate error rates of
about 0.2% and point six percent
respectively and even lower kind of
cycle era times or even just above cycle
era times the readout was a bit not so
as perfect but it's something that we're
hoping to fix quite soon and still quite
spectable at around four percent error
rate so kind of this preface is to say
that assuming you have such a device one
might consider fifty four cubits with
you know that kind of aerate to be
something that you'd really like to play
with how do you start to use it
effectively to make meaningful
statements about progress towards
applications and what are these
application areas I'm going to talk
about a few of them but some of the ones
we heard about today this morning and
the cue AOA and other optimization
techniques session so kind of these
relation representations or quantum
machine learnings using quantum neural
networks we heard about yesterday
and of course quantum simulation that
I'll talk a little bit about today
simulating truly quantum systems like
the the nucleons inside of a nucleus or
perhaps atoms and molecules or their
electrons and these have these nice
representation properties that we
believe that it's sort of hard to
represent very correlated quantum
systems using classical systems natively
so what does it mean really to to use a
post supremacy quantum device so imagine
that you have one over here and my goal
is to do is an interesting computation
as close to classically intractable as
possible so what does that that mean
what it doesn't mean is doing the
largest possible experiment you can
squint at and see a curve through
fidelity and accuracy tend to matter as
we've seen in a lot of the other
competitions between quantum and
classical that if your accuracy is not
good enough you can just do a kind of
crappy mean field method because
remember unlike supremacy these problems
are probably going to have reasonable
structure they are probably engineered
by human beings who have been working
with them for a long time we probably
have decent methods to begin with so if
you're not good enough you're probably
going to get beat by a much simpler
method and my prediction and I hope to
substantiate this a little bit is that
doing an interesting simulation beyond
20 cubits will be extremely difficult
without error reduction techniques even
if you have great Fidelity's and so let
me do a little back-of-the-envelope
calculation for you one that can be
easily followed if you'd like so imagine
that I have say a twenty cubits system
that I'm interested in I'm going to
prepare the ground state of hydrogen
won't need to know anything about
quantum simulation to follow this I'm
gonna assume that I have a perfect gate
sequence for this and it's about depth
20 and so if I use my notes naive
fidelity estimate and I just kind of
product these all together I get a
respectable fidelity of about 80 percent
so if you did a 20 cubed experiment
depth 20 you'd probably be pretty happy
with 80% on today's devices what does
that mean for my predictions that I
would like to make so hydrogen has a gap
from the ground to the first excited
state of about half a heart tree and so
if I just take that fidelity and I dump
all of the error into my first excited
state so the most optimistic error that
I can make rather than hitting the rest
of the spectrum I get an error that's
about 0.1 Hartree which to give you a
reference point it's around one or two
orders of magnitude worse than I would
like to do and so this is both a too
optimistic and too pessimistic estimate
because truly I care about energy
differences rather than absolute
energies and you might get some
correlated error cancellation but the
point is even for this kind of small
system this is already kind of bordering
on hard to interpret and so today I'm
going to talk a little bit about error
correction and can it help us on misc
devices because I think there's a
pervasive feeling in the field that sort
of error correction is this thing that
undergoes a phase transition in more
ways than one where it's essentially
hurts you dramatically for a very long
period of time and then when you cross
this magical threshold suddenly
everything works perfectly but I think
the basic ideas of redundancy and kind
of other things that are within it might
still be useful in the near-term regime
to help us discover more things about
applications and so just to kind of
broaden it a little bit from only
talking about quantum simulation I
thought an interesting version of
quantum machine learning that hasn't
been talked too much today hasn't been
talked too much yet but one is this kind
of quantum kernels that people use where
you try to do a classification problem
and you divide up your system based on
some complicated unitary the idea being
say if you have like a super premise II
level device you could do a very
complicated circuit and make very very
intricate patterns that would be hard to
classify for some sets of data on a
sickle device but one of them to
emphasize is that once you start to add
noise that sort of thing might blur some
of these islands together and a
classical approximation might do just
fine so anytime you're talking about
using one of these noisy devices on a
real application you have to be
cognizant of the way noise changes your
ability to approximate it more easily
and so there is kind of one point that I
wanted to make that I haven't heard too
much talked about so everyone talks
about using a quantum device to beat a
classical one it's some task but I
actually think there's a much more
modest goal that we should strive for
which is as many of you might know some
of our best provable performance
computer science algorithms are not
always the ones we choose to use in
practice for various reasons and so
arguably one of my hopeful uses of an
early quantum device is to learn what
actually works well on a quantum device
outside the regime that I can easily
simulate classically so a very simple
example of this would be imagine you had
like a the QA Oh a circuit you saw from
this morning and I'll introduce those a
little bit more in a second but I just
have say on 50 cubits some on sots
and because it's variational if I
doubled it up in principle I should do a
little bit better and I'd like to know
how much better I'm doing but in
practice on a 50 qubit device with too
much noise I add more variational
parameters and my answer gets worse
because the amount of noise didn't I
couldn't compensate for that and so it
becomes a question of first I would like
a goal of at least being able to prove
things about primitives or explore
primitives that are not yet present and
then I can use that to help me get to
this more lofty goal of how to use the
chip to go beyond current classical
results and so hopefully some of the
techniques that I'm going to talk about
will be useful for this so a lot of the
algorithms that you've heard about
already stem from this nice simple
primitive of device compatible
implementations which was often what you
might talk about is given a task and you
can design a circuit to perform it that
is hopefully optimal you get your gate
counts down you get your complexity
results down and if everything works and
it fits in your device you get out
forty-two or the answer to life and
everything but if it doesn't quite go in
you might not get anything out and so
the alternative is given the task and
the current architecture find the best
solution possible by means of sort of
iteratively updating these schemes and
there's a lot of course algorithms that
fit within this and I'll talk about only
a few and so the idea of this is of
course to use the quantum computer where
it's needed offload any kind of mundane
computations that you might have onto a
neighboring classical device that's well
developed and most of them follow a
simple pattern which is you're rewriting
some optimization problem that you'd
like as this minimization of some
expected value of a quantum wave
function and you've seen many talks
about this today but essentially you're
going to have some inputs given by these
coefficients and you're simply going to
ask your quantum circuit many times what
are the values of these poly operators
so this is a task that it's quite easy
for a quantum computer given enough
depth and adding all of these together
is of course quite easy for a classical
computer so you combine the two of these
and you get out one of these hybrid
schemes essentially and so you've seen
this in other context today and I won't
belabor it too much but the idea is to
simply use the quantum device as this
object which stores a very complicated
probability distribution for you of
sorts and our belief in this that it
might be powerful comes from supremacy
like arguments of course that we have
such distributions that are hard to
sample from but of course using it is
quite complex and then I'm going to
sample only a little bit of information
from that feed it back to my CPU and try
to do better and better and this fits
kind of in a lot of different problems
so in a nutshell these are essentially
problems often which map between say
eigenvalue problems and minimizations
over some parameter ization and today
I'm gonna really focus on a different
part of that which is apart from the
numerous applications which is say
chemistry nuclear physics QA Oh a as you
heard about this morning machine
learning is what happens in the presence
of coherent and incoherent errors for
these types of algorithms can we still
learn about these primitives even if we
have substantial noise
and so it's helpful I think based on
people I've talked to here that perhaps
have not seen an explicit example of
this to walk through at least one just
briefly so what does one of these
experiments look like in practice this
is a kind of a getting it starting to
age but it's still a good experiment of
course and if you just take two cubits
so I'm gonna examine a hydrogen
experiment and I run my quantum circuit
down here and just map up to exactly
what's happening on my chips here I have
one parameter izybelle piece down and
this z-rotation I'm going to measure my
different operators and then just
feedback and hopefully through the
optimization of this get a better and
better approximation to the ground state
and so what's the result of this so what
this graph is is if I take my two
hydrogen atoms and I rip them apart what
is the energy as a function of that
pulling apart and I'm doing each one of
these problems separately so this
variational quantum eigen solver
experiment that I talked about is the
parts in red and the parts in blue are
the attempt to do that with the same
system with a phase estimation
experiment so if I'm recalling correctly
we had actually hoped at the outset of
this that the device was good enough
that the combination of majority voting
error correction on the phase estimation
would bring us better than the
variational result but what we found was
that was not really the case and we
wanted to dig deeper into why this was
actually happening and what we found is
of course that because this thing is
only two qubits I can go back and tell
you exactly what this angle theta should
be in the ideal case it's not too hard
and then I calibrate my device as best I
can
I'd plug that angle in and I see what
happens and that particular calculation
or that particular sequence of events
what you get is all of these green dots
and what you do if you do this
variational loop is the red dots and so
in some ways this optimization loop is
performing say an on-the-fly calibration
since it doesn't really care about what
the the labels on your angles are but
it's able to just update and kind of
correct for things that were hard to see
in a kind of fully integrated experiment
for just calibration so that leads us to
believe that we're at least a little
robust to certain types of errors which
are sort of calibration like or
over-rotate
errors so that makes us feel pretty good
about that
but this is not the type of area that
one would might be most concerned with
so we started some work even while I was
here at LBNL I'm going beyond this brown
state without more qubits or gates and
so the original hope was actually to go
and get excited States which we did but
imagine you're in a situation where
you've already done this and you have
some great reference wavefunction and I
would like to do only additional
measurements on that I'm going to build
up a classical generalized eigenvalue
problem so once again one of these
quantum classical kind of couplings and
from the solutions of this generalized
eigenvalue problem we're going to give
you not only excited States but a lot
more at the same time so I'll walk you
through sort of how this works and the
results you get but then I'm going to
have to take a little bit of a detour
into error correction to tell you why it
does what it does
so how does this what is the general
idea of this sort of subspace expansion
that we're going to perform and the hope
is to learn the action of the
Hamiltonian in a subspace around the
state that I've prepared so what do I
mean if I've done my variational
calculation successfully across this
nice manifold and I found this point
which is an optimum here then I would
like to learn things about how the
Hamiltonian acts on my system sort of
around that state without knowing any
detailed knowledge of my actual state
itself and I can do this by introducing
a set of operators oh that are going to
sort of act and probe on this space so
I'm going to act my Hamiltonian on this
Oh which acts on the state and probe
with the same set of states so if you're
more of an applied math bent this
sometimes goes by a name like the
larrikin approximation but it's nice
because it creates this closed dynamics
in a subspace and so if I take care of
all the other parts correctly the end of
the day I'm set up with this matrix
equation that's off line so I've
measured all of these matrix elements
individually and I've written this in a
suggestive way which is to say that
rather than perform these OHS which I'll
tell you what they are and how to pick
them in a second I'm actually just
dressing my Hamiltonian with these O's
beforehand and changing the measurements
that I do on the states that I prepare
so in that way up to usually kind of
individual rotations I don't make my
circuit any
longer I still keep the same amount of
quantum resources so something happened
it was a little bit surprising we were
able to show an experiment so this is
the plot of the error versus the the
distance for the same type of molecular
curve but now an experiment we did with
earth on Siddiqui and in fact we'd made
a little bit of a prediction of this in
the theory paper but the reviewers told
us that they didn't believe us and we
needed an experiment and what they
didn't believe was so this these
different lines are each different
collections of those expansion operators
oh I mentioned so I being the identity
is just the original vqe result and as I
added more of these operators and keep
in mind this is kind of a way of taking
measurements that I do incoherently and
finding a way in which they would
coherently ad in principle I'm able to
remove the remaining area of my system
sometimes by a few orders of magnitude
even and so if we believe that this vqe
result also took care of the the
coherent errors then it looks like a lot
of what's been removed is the incoherent
errors so how can you do that with kind
of this just incoherent averaging and an
offline eigenvalue problem so this was a
little bit of the mystery that led me
down a path towards a bit more quantum
error correction so I am NOT going to
talk in too much detail about quantum
error correction I find people sit in
one of two camps within quantum
computing which is they're either
absolute experts and know everything
that's about every decoder that's ever
been written or they assume that someone
else's problem and they're waiting for
the logical qubits so I'm going to tell
you just enough to kind of get the
picture of why this result works and how
we might start to import tools from
quantum error correction that might
still be useful for us so how does
classical error correction work at a
glance it works through some combination
of redundancy and a reasonable model of
errors so you can imagine that if you
encode redundantly as zero as three
zeros or one as three ones and assume
that single bit flips are probably more
likely than all of them moving at the
same time then a simple scheme like
majority voting can allow you to correct
errors and of course there is a long
history of quantum error correction
where due to no-cloning theorem x' and
measurement destroying information
people thought that perhaps this wasn't
possible but luckily as you all know it
now is and the trick is to use
redundancy in the form of symmetries so
I'm just protecting against bit flip
errors here but instead of this kind of
basic redundancy of bits that I had
before I'm going to encode it into some
subspace of the symmetries which I
choose and I'm going to choose them such
that they protect me against my
reasonable model of errors which is
usually that local errors are much more
likely than global errors and if I'm
successful in measuring these symmetries
it does not in fact destroy my
information and I'm allowed to recover
my information in that regard so a
sketch of the type of code that I'm
talking about so they're often referred
to as stabilizer codes where the
stabilizers are these symmetries that
I've engineered into my system in the
ideal case you're in this nice blue code
word space and error takes you out you
detect it and recover if you take too
many errors you might get a logical
error which takes you into another blue
state by accident and if you're doing a
logical operation you want to
purposefully move between these states
so you often just choose a commuting set
of poly operators denote this as the
stabilizer group you define the code
words or nice parts of this blue space
to be the plus one eigenstates of these
operators so for example for the
repetition code the operators which
generate this are these and then of
course you'll have logical operators so
you might have just been able to see by
inspection that applying three X's to
this zero state will then give you the
one state doing more interesting
operations is of course quite a an
endeavor when you're in more complicated
codes but for the purposes of this this
is about all you'll need to know so how
does a error correction work in some
sense so in a very broad sense you'll
need to do some measurement of these
syndromes after an error and then you
recover the state as quickly as possible
but if you're working more in the
near-term regime and you say well it's
not as important to me to do this type
of operation maybe I'm okay with just
dramatically reducing the error rate
even if it's not quite scalable yet and
I can start to borrow things from the
scalable regime so if you were to take a
different point of view maybe the only
thing I really like to do
to say it's more likely that or it's not
so likely after a short amount of time
that I've taken on these logical errors
so most of what I want to do is just
remove this space and focus only on
things that have remained in the correct
subspace and so you can do this by just
constructing projectors from those
symmetry generators that I mentioned
before and the advantage of doing it in
the way I'm about to describe which you
might not see the details of yet is that
it will tend to reduce errors
considerably for small experiments it
allows you to use a device in the lab
today to test code properties even if
the code is has fairly non-local
stabilizers and it's like error
detection but without explicit
stabilizers and you can explore some
recovery channels in this way so to make
one clear distinction before everyone
always asks the difference between this
and post-selection is actually that I'm
not going to measure the stabilizers
explicitly I'm going to measure only
transversal operators and average out
the space in a somewhat indirect way but
hopefully one that you'll see is quite
experimentally interesting so how do we
do this just to remind you how these
projected projectors work so if I use
this projector for a symmetry si and
I've hopefully engineered it so that
common errors e anticommute with it then
this projector will remove any component
of a wave function that's had that error
applied to it and kind of the the
projected density matrix version of this
is just that you get this sort of
renormalized density matrix and so what
we're going to do is actually not
recover the quantum state my goal
instead is going to be that I often only
want some nice observable like an energy
of the system or a kind of it's spin
Magnus a ssin and all I'm going to ask
for is that I'm going to get a better
average value for some operator a than I
could before and the way I'm going to do
it is I'm simply going to re express
this as this kind of incoherent sum that
you've seen before
over all of these operators within the
projector and the important caveat here
is that it's over only these kind of
transversal poly operator measurements I
never have to attach an Scylla and do
true
syndra measurements which tend to kill
so-called pseudo thresholds because of
the way they soak up errors and you
might be looking at this and say huh
doesn't that look like it contains an
exponential number of terms in it
aha I've got you well you'd be right but
you wouldn't be right quite correctly
about the scaling yet because we've
chosen these things to be in the plus 1
eigen space by their construction in
fact if there's no errors in the state
this operation of kind of going through
a loop and choosing a random polyframe
at the end of the determined by these
symmetries does not actually affect the
statistics of measurement if my state is
perfect so I need to do the same number
of repetitions in this wonderful ideal
case and as I lose fidelity some of
those symmetries start to flip and I get
sort of a plus minus effect that then
averages out the incorrect parts of my
space so I can do this essentially
without needing any extra control qubits
and on any real code that I want
assuming that I've managed to prepare
the initial state and so this is kind of
the trick that we're going to use to
implement near-term error correction in
a way so you might say well that was a
nice story but didn't you say something
about a generalized eigenvalue problem
can you get back to that so suppose that
you don't know the simmetry subspace or
that the problem has a logical
Hamiltonian as well where you prefer
some code States over others so if I
rewrite this as some general projector
where I get to choose the weights and
then I'm going to minimize over these
coefficients where my Hamiltonian will
be the Hamiltonian my code space that
goes up in energy if I break or violate
one of my nice symmetries and I'd like
to subject it to being like kind of a
norm actual quantum state and so you
might look at that for a second and if
you've done a bit of chemistry in the
past you'll immediately know the exact
solution to this equation you haven't
you might have to think about it a
little bit and it'll be exactly the
thing we wrote down before this
generalized eigenvalue problem solves
this particular instance exactly so we
had essentially intuited a way to get
the right projectors and this was the
effect that was happening is we were
learning code space projectors that were
inherent in our system and this was
removing additional noise in our
experiment so how does this work in
practice of
just blows a few quick examples so we
wanted to just evaluate how good does a
device need to be at least in the best
possible case to start seeing benefits
from this type of procedure because you
might be thinking in your head that
you've heard of thresholds and pseudo
thresholds in the order of like 10 to
the minus 5 for error rates and so maybe
this is still not useful so we looked at
the 5 1 3 code which means 5 physical
qubits comprise 1 logical qubit with
distance 3 and we looked at first
recovery only and sort of this memory
model and we set each of our five qubits
to have a depolarizing channel on it
with some probability P and you only
need to pay attention to the lowest line
for the purposes of this versus this
bare physical qubit which was what would
happen if this was just a single qubit
getting that depolarizing channel and we
shockingly found a pseudo threshold of
up to 50% depolarizing on each of the
individual qubits which is to say if you
have any error below that which most
devices of ours do of course you get a
substantial benefit from this encoding
so this is of course just recovery on a
very simple model but it gives us a nice
kind of guess that these techniques
might be more applicable than we might
have thought in the near term so another
quick example in course you don't have
enough qubits to afford a different
encoding is that sometimes you have
these symmetries naturally in addition
to the ones you might engineer in your
system so for fermionic systems we know
we have spin symmetries and other things
like that and you can even focus on
easier symmetries that you might be
interested in and in these cases there's
no reference it's just always beneficial
to invoke one of these kind of symmetry
projections to help your system out so I
think I'm reaching near to the end of my
time so I will just quickly summarize by
saying that we think that even with a
great device it's going to be pretty
challenging to simulate some of these
these systems and it's going to be even
challenging to create experiments where
I learn how to do better application
quantum experiments and what I hope to
have at least told you not only about
the technique that we worked on and we
have hope for but just to give you all
hope that there are ideas from error
correction that are going to be a lot
more powerful I think in the near term
then we might have given them credit
for originally as we start to introduce
more aspects of era correction in a more
heuristic way I'm hopeful it's going to
let us bring down errors in a new and
interesting way and that there might be
more before this crazy error correction
transition so with that I'd like to
thank all of my collaborators that
helped me with this work and all of you
for listening
thanks a lot case where you're better
off actually using it for this type of
correction rather than just removing and
using like the more aggressive mapping
yeah it's a great question so we've
actually seen in a fair number of cases
so people have attempted to remove these
symmetries manually from the hamiltonian
often what you get out is fewer qubits
which is nice but a dramatically
increased in complexity and the
Hamiltonian itself or in some cases in
the representation and so when you kind
of trade-off the increased complexity of
the gates and like things that you have
to do you find that sometimes it is
still beneficial to use the simpler but
more redundant encoding and then
especially if you then use the the
symmetry Corrections on top of it I'm
Sur there's instances where this is not
the case but we've seen a few where this
is still the way to go
basically Thanks
yep so you mentioned at the beginning of
your talk that the reagent readout error
is the kind of most significance that
the error correction schemes that you
proposed rely heavily on I was wondering
how much to significant to read of
errors impact to the error correction
scheme since you have so for these
schemes so that has a big impact of
course it's actually interesting that in
fault tolerant error correction for the
surface code despite its heavy
dependence on measurement it is a little
more a it's a little more robust to that
type of error I think you can tolerate
up to say one percent error in the
measurement whereas your gates need to
be a little bit more precise but you're
right in that we are making an attempt
and a great way to bring down that
measurement error but in fact the basic
redundancy helps us with our measurement
errors even more so in some cases than
our gate errors so yes there is this
compounding effect but the fact that you
can kind of majority vote away even if
you use a very basic like repetition
code your measurement flaws you still
tend to come out ahead but I'd say in
the long term we definitely want that
measurement error reduced greatly from
what we have
how do you say Oh in order to get this
generalized eigenvalue problem ah
so when you're doing the generalized
eigenvalue problem version you do have
to rather than doing it stochastically
like we did before you do after you have
to select them so when we were it kind
of is problem dependent I would say
because you're a little bit more
constrained by the number that you're
gonna do when we did excited states the
choices were natural for fermions which
were single fermionic cetaceans when
you're trying to do it for error
correction we basically the ways in
which we did it where we essentially
would choose stochastic samplings up
from that and then kind of optimize on
top of it so it was not a perfect
procedure but yeah I guess this is kind
of the combination of the two if you're
interested in excited states and error
correction but it is difficult in
general to pick out exactly the right
stabilizers from this massive sum so
how did the Google Hardware and it's
like crosstalk either help or hurt the
the error correction in your opinion um
I in talking so I'm not the right person
to ask about the details of our
crosstalk I have been told that our
crosstalk is incredibly low compared to
other architectures of course if you
have large correlated errors this will
just create a greater density of errors
and for methods that are implementing
full kind of surface code error
correction I believe there's results
which say that it's not really the
correlated errors that kill you it's
simply the raw density of errors so if
those correlated errors are much less
likely than the the kind of local errors
it won't matter too much but of course
generally we just need to bring those
types of Fidelity's down as far as I can
tell if you're doing active measurements
those aren't particularly bad except in
the case when you have too many
thanks for the questions and let's time
[Applause]